[Music]
if you guys were offered a free home
would you take it
[ __ ] yeah yep don't to beat up an old
lady hold on wait is it haunted though
be me I'm sorry I got a paper to sell
and I can't live in it I start to pay
property taxes that sounds bad you can
live in it if you want proven haunted or
some people just got scared and left Wow
if you don't believe in haunted houses
you just gotta repaint it and paint the
ghosts away okay so the only ghost gets
stuck into the wall the only caveat here
is that if you decide to take this free
home who has it has been known to be
haunted you must remove it from that
location this is a trailer hole with the
[ __ ] it's not how do you move this [ __ ]
to be what they wanted or they want to
give it to a person that will restore it
so restore and move from that's a lot of
[ __ ] demands for a person that don't
want their own damn house where is okay
so pick up the house and move you want
to give me the hots for free yeah bolted
from the ground first and then you have
to remove the ghost and then leave so
they could come back and restore it or
you restore it
no no get the [ __ ] this is the house
pick up the [ __ ] house go this way
and it's old and [ __ ] broken but they
want you to perfectly make it back to
how it used to be and then bolt it back
down what kind of houses is that you
could just unbolt it from the ground
this is a house in Louisiana and it's
built in the late 20s early 30s a boudu
house like above-ground foundation table
oh that's scary that house just looks
like a box that looks like that the
house that you make in elementary school
it's a [ __ ] box
you make the door and you make the
little windows because the windows are
even symmetrical you see that the ones
on the leg wandering right next to each
other once cross-eyed windows and the
ones on like windows on the opposite
sides of a thing a window rear what the
[ __ ] well here's the rest of the house
that's cool I like that it looks like a
barn yeah I [ __ ] with that house so
there have been reports of people seeing
this woman
looking through the window at night Oh a
victorian-era woman OH floating stairs
floating downstairs
airiest of them all the question is is
she nice no because if she was a nice
ghost I'd be cool with that like she's
floating down yeah hey I'm gonna be gone
for a month can you watch the place and
I come back well if you could have like
a like a roommate type of solvation I'd
go I think I could nail the market
roommates miss company miss ah ha ha ha
get this house instead of having an S
you have a Miss so what do you expect to
happen while you're gone like the gulls
I didn't call you up hey someone told
you you can't really get a text from
your ghost I do right true teleport yeah
she she'll come to my hotel
but don't go stuff like jurisdictions
have their own like a little like thing
oh they're trapped there I don't know
the rules I go skiing you know they just
switch grace the line is it the the land
that's haunted or is it the house that's
why they won't remove the best way to
learn is to the movies and usually it's
that house so if you move the house the
ghost comes with the house
I'm guessing no I think it's the plot of
land well the plot or whatever but
nobody in any other movie have I've ever
seen
Liuba house they're not the right way
why not must stay in this house
although fix it walk is the real quick
yeah no the first time I had ever heard
about an entire building being moved was
for our wedding but like that the place
where we had our wedding had been
removed from its original location I was
like what the [ __ ] people do well yeah
so but that building that we're talking
about was like me out of stones you know
it's [ __ ] like like a nice bill thing
this thing looks like you would fall
apart the moment you have it in the air
I heard that ghosts don't like folk
music so if you learn how to play the
acoustic guitar and sing folk songs yeah
well if it's like a ghost in like
Georgia what if they're not even ghosts
at all what if it's like you know we
always talk about like aliens and [ __ ]
whatever it's these ghosts are like do
kinds of aliens and then they come and
they visit and only some people can they
only like Victorian fashion and they get
stuck to the house or the way they look
ha ha the way they look looks like that
era or whatever the [ __ ] but that's just
out there spy you know when we sent off
like that golden disc into the yeah and
then that's like short who we are
that's what thank god that's how I
thought we looked and dressed so then
they dressed like that coming back oh I
don't think we said that sent that Godin
disco when we had a Victorian clothes
they did send like music and [ __ ] like
videos one of the 1920s where it was
where people wearing those type of
clothing Victorian era when is that
1920s 18 something good and this wasn't
that long ago so it must be the power
line I think it was 18 something 1801
yeah so the house was built in 1920 or
she probably was still living that [ __ ]
is a teleport and mass time traveler
she must be stuck to the land then
that's what I'm saying I think it was
built in 1920 she never [ __ ] lived
and so this landlords down there cuz
you're like take the house haha get rid
of the ghost but the ghost is still stay
there they don't know how to go sound
like we did we just mapped this [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] Sherlock ghosted this [ __ ] I
don't know then they need to remodel it
I think that's what it is they just need
to get a hipster in there and you know
how they get these like I did but not
not the hipster episode the murder house
the gay one thank you want were they
were the vinyl suits the gay guys and
maybe [ __ ] the ghost flesh it's kind
of horny there's a house in LA it's like
a Victorian home right let's just
haunted and there's this gay couple and
then they got like many [ __ ] they got
this one um vinyl suit to [ __ ] in and
then the ghost possessed that [ __ ]
vinyl suit well the whole story is that
this house has housed many murders and
whoever dies in this house is their soul
stuck there but they can be like human
light like you can interact with them
and people don't know that they're
ghosts but one of the couples that lived
and was gay and he had a [ __ ] vinyl
suit you don't like those vinyl suits
were you just all like just mouth just
was like yeah on that BDSM type yeah
they [ __ ] pregnant by a [ __ ] ghost
demon and she had like the devil child
or some [ __ ] yeah it was [ __ ] nuts
did you guys grow up but I wonder if the
sex was great though cuz she seemed to
like it no but she seems scared
remembered towards the end she was like
I thought girls like a little bit of
scary sex okay did you grab the girl
with like known haunted houses in your
neighborhood like that everybody knew
about in the neighborhood because
there's one in my area like no matter
who you talks he doesn't matter what
school does matter how old they are
everybody knows about that haunted house
that's there for me was the abandoned
Asylum that was like the haunted place
in in Downey oh there's a place in
Orange County that it's like still no no
but finally I think after like 20 years
someone finally bought the property and
knocked it down and they built new
houses there but I from what I heard no
one no one still like lives there
Thursday I got you talk to you I got
time for ghosts though my life is so
[ __ ] dope if a ghost was to [ __ ] with
me right now I'm like [ __ ] can I put
you in my blog I don't have time for
this haunting [ __ ] you know like let's
say I bought my first house write this
[ __ ] haunting me I'm like dude
[ __ ] you man I put so much money into
this [ __ ] we're living together and I'm
gonna annoy the [ __ ] out of this ghost
there's nothing big I believe that yeah
I don't believe in ghosts
but I'm not gonna [ __ ] with the chance
that I'm wrong so I'm not doing anything
shady like in terms of Matthew and Ouija
boards and [ __ ] like that
I don't believe in it but same time if I
am wrong I am NOT gonna be haunted for
the rest of my life well I'm not gonna
summon the demon but if but it could be
a good bar closet like you said I'm
hoping I mean well I hope that the ghost
is a good guy cuz there's a good spirit
in a bad spirit
so I heard right and then like I could
get some good wisdom from the good
spirit but if it's a bad spirit we're
gonna have to compete cuz man I'm petty
dude I'm like [ __ ] if I die one
day I'm coming back just like may
remember David's kill all right
was like I'll come back and I'll yeah oh
grudge I'll be like when I'm [ __ ] old
and retired and all that stuff I'm
coming to get your ass
what if it's living in a different
dimension you can't access that goes cuz
we're from different ghost dimensions
yeah maybe by that time I hope I can
Ober to his debenture you know I mean
ghost uber I'll [ __ ] put a GPS on his
ass so when I die I'll [ __ ] teleport
be like whatever me [ __ ]
[ __ ] man and then you'll be to that what
if he doesn't remember you know at all
do you get the satisfaction Oh true no I
think I would because I beat I'll hold
the grudge it's kind of like if someone
made an accident right and he crashed
his car into yours and you're like man
that was my first car you son of a [ __ ]
they're like whoops sorry and they don't
even remember that but you get the
satisfaction of one day putting dynamite
in their car and blowing it Oh oops I
don't know it's still satisfying I don't
know to me I feel like I really do
believe that if anything would be
haunted it would be the land not
necessarily the building I feel like it
just so happens to be there or if like
over time and then you know how they say
like places gand up getting haunted
because so much negative energy has been
trapped there what's that movie
poltergeist yeah that's like that the
Native American land right like that
so I don't know I feel like tell us
about movie though maybe what can you do
is like the [ __ ] ground is hot if you
take the house off the ground does the
ghost feel naked like all upset you to
remove what is hiding it yeah right this
was just a ghost on the ground like I
would gladly I would gladly [ __ ] with an
American ghost before I [ __ ] what a
Japanese ghost those Asian goes like
slow moving
no that's a vampire that's a Chinese
vampire I'll [ __ ] with those guys
they're cool Jackie it's like the ring
The Grudge that the creepy and [ __ ] they
come up
you thinks I'm a [ __ ] for being scared
of that what do you mean I was telling
you like how like the scariest movie I
think of to this day like the one that
really rocked me was watching the ring
in your life yeah both versions this is
the concept of the ring is [ __ ]
because when that movie first came out I
saw it three times in the theater and
like by the third time a brief I was I
was the one like I was in my sister's so
I'd be like this and if he likes boy hey
that little that scary would know I'm
back then I had really long black hair
and so it didn't you didn't it make you
feel when you found out why you're like
ah I feel so bad you're stuck in the
well and [ __ ] you're just trying to
[ __ ] communicate that you've been
done wrong you know and then you
empathize for the ghost but in the very
beginning when she's calling out the TV
the thing that I want to do is kick her
in the [ __ ] face so she goes back in
just like in those scary movies yeah now
like that happens will you only have a
guy phone - what if she crawls out the
iPhone just her head [ __ ] break those
[ __ ] fingers off well knowing me I'm
probably watching porn so the hand comes
out I'm using that me stick your lips up
like headfirst trying to get out and I'm
like who's a mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]